[Music]
all right we're live as everyone fills
in hi everybody hope you're having fun
at next today we're here to talk to you
today about cloud file store for managed
files for your applications
I'm Todd hunt I'm the product manager
for cloud file store been at Google for
about two-and-a-half years as you can
see from my picture my main hobby is
rock climbing
that's from up in Tuolumne Mathis crest
awesome climb and good morning I'm Kashi
I'm the engineering manager for the
cloud files for product I don't have a
hobby picture up there but unlike my
friend tad who likes to climb up I'm
afraid of heights I like to explore the
horizontal territory so biking is my
passion and I used to think I'm really
into biking till I was told that unless
I do this year to the Portland ride I
can't claim that I'm a biker so I did
that SCP a couple weekends back so you
can see how we tussle right one likes to
scale up and I like to scale out never
mind
back dad alright so hopefully you like
woken up from all that what we hope you
walk away from today from our
presentation is how cloud file store can
help you simplify and accelerate your
journey in the public cloud so let's see
so introducing cloud file store bita you
know many of you have been telling us
that you want a native manage
first-class offering for files in Google
Cloud can everybody hear me okay in the
back all right
awesome cool we'll talk a little bit
about use cases later but for now let's
say kind of it's gonna unblock your
small and your midsize you know kind of
compute clusters in scale and enterprise
applications you know things that need
access to shared file systems NFS and
shared file systems are like the
arteries of the enterprise workflows so
it's about time we had a file offering I
think and so we're super excited to to
get this out there for you all we just
launched a beta on July 12th and so it's
really early days we're already seeing
really amazing update
we announced it about 10 business days
prior and when we launched our la region
and we've got about 1500 people signing
up with interest and so really really
pretty cool so let me just take a minute
to talk about the ecosystem you know
where does file store fit in right and
so this is like the taxonomy of storage
systems in Google Cloud today you know
we're not going to spend any time on
anything other than file I just wanted
to show you all this so that you can see
the rich ecosystem that file stores are
part of and get a view into the
cutting-edge computer science that we're
doing here in Google Cloud you know so
that you can run your apps much better
so if we zoom in on structure on the
unstructured storage systems you know
that's file object and block you know
each are good at solving different
problems in in sort of different domains
you know if we take a file centric view
on these domains right shared file
systems are critical building blocks in
enterprise workflows but if you're gonna
manually stand up you know Linux
instances and build your own file
servers that's complex and time
consuming and then you're still in the
business of managing filers keeping them
up to date and so on you can try object
storage for your workloads that need
file but sometimes making object storage
try and look like file is let's say it
just makes us grumpy and kind of leave
it at that if the if there's not an
impedance mismatch with your workload
sometimes it works really well but if
there is they you need a random i/o and
then it's kind of a disaster and then
finally we have some really innovative
persistent disk features which are
virtual disks such that you can mount
read-only the same virtual disk on you
know a whole huge number of VMs but it's
not writable right so while persistent
disk is good for certain kind of
unstructured data it's not an awesome
for sharing files in fact that's what
now we're guitar storage was was
invented for and so that's what this is
so with that you understand hopefully
we're in the oil portfolio of Google
managed native storage solutions for
unstructured Shore files for Hudson now
let you tell me let me tell you a little
bit of things right off the bat as that
said we launched beta woohoo so in fact
right after this talk I encourage all of
you to play with it share feedback many
of you in the room have already done so
being a mate managed native Google
products you get all the goodness that
comes with Google it's managed fully
supported by a dedicated as three team
it's integrated with kubernetes engine
and GC compute engine and that GA time
you'll get zonal three nines of
availability its first party which will
come with its own use cases that tad
will not walk it through cool so I'm not
gonna read all these words it's it's a
lot of words a lot of you are taking
pictures that's I think an awesome way
but let me talk to you about kind of the
highlights here that we've designed file
store to be great at many enterprise
workloads in particular we've tuned it
already at beta for for kind of these
top five you know in the render if
you're in the rendering space if you're
building render farms you know you might
have many many compute instances maybe
preemptable instances that are spinning
up like batch processing workloads here
you know that's great we've tuned it for
that if you're migrating enterprise
applications to the cloud does NFS v3
and does all the basic NFS operations
that you're you're used to you might be
running infrastructure supporting
websites like WordPress or stuff like
that
and so that didn't tends to need lots of
small file you know high performance
small file access we got you covered
there too on the media side we've got
artists using file store to collaborate
on their desktops and their desktop
workstations while they're doing doing
some you know doing this real-time kind
of you know building the 3d models that
it will eventually be rendered into the
movies and in fact if you go to Moscone
West up on the second floor we've got a
team of artists back over in a corner
that are actually doing a real-time
commercial building an animated
for GCP they're running virtual desktops
in the cloud in GCP using scale-out GPUs
for doing really high quality real-time
rendering and they're using file store
behind the scenes to share all the files
between all the artists so pretty cool
and then can't leave out home
directories you know own directories are
often done on shared file systems in
order for management you know keeping
data you know safe and kind of protected
and into do backups and so on and so all
good all great use cases for for file
store so we're introducing the file
store product in two tiers right off the
bat as you can probably tell the biggest
difference between the two tiers is
performance in fact the only difference
is price and performance we are the best
judge of the application you have at
hand but we have a few suggestions and
the recommendations for you if you find
that you're running a read/write random
read/write data intensive workload for
example a simulation then you may want
in to opt in for the premium tier to tap
into the full iOS that we can export to
you on the other hand if you expect that
your application is more cash friendly
then you can pay a lot less and get away
with the standard here and get the cash
rate performance but as we all know
performance tuning is an art so you're
the best judge of what your application
needs apart from the trifecta of IRS
throughput and latency and we've shared
some numbers but you'll be the best
judge when you try our product the other
design principle that we had in mind is
to make it super simple for you to
reason about your storage to the extent
that you when you go ahead and create
your file store instance at that point
we will tell you what sort of
performance guarantees you should expect
so no more complex modeling to figure
out how that performance is going to
weary the second thing you're gonna get
a really simple billing model again when
you create the file store instance based
on the capacity you choose
you're gonna know how much you will be
built on an hourly basis it is not gonna
change because you throw a wearing
workload over time that does not seem
fair and we didn't want to do it so
those are the design principles you can
read the numbers off of the charts but
there will be more Docs later and again
as I said you will get a chance to run
with the product that's a lot of numbers
and explanation we have done for a while
tad do you think we should show whether
this thing actually works or not zero I
see a demo yeah okay that's let's do it
I can you switch the demo
so we were talking about the UI to
create the file sure there's this
standard G cui you would see that there
is a file stored product in the storage
category now woohoo that's us you click
on that and it takes you to the list of
all files store instances you have
created so far so let me create one
while we're talking about it so I go to
the create page and like any GC instance
we will give it a name let's call it
live demo because what better name to
pick we talked about the tiers so let me
pick these standard two year for now
which is the one which I would pick if I
have a sequential workload possibly one
which is cache friendly right and I
would pay a lot less I would pick a
region so let me pick Europe West for a
in the file share properties I would
have to pick a mount point so let me
call it live mount point and right now
you can see I can choose whatever size I
want so let me go the minimum which is
one terabytes on the right side we show
you the performance numbers it gets let
me get this going and it's going to
create in the background and it's going
to show me a spinner that the file sure
is being created in the meantime let me
go to this line and these are all the
file shares I have mounted from a single
GC instance for example you can see
there are two standard filers which are
roughly when it happened two and half
terabytes there are two premiums both
around two and a half terabytes here is
a filer that I have previously created a
file share instance if I click on it it
shows me the amount points that I can
use and then mount here
if I do it correctly
so what that is happening maybe I
changed my mind that I don't want it to
be a one terabyte filer maybe your
workload grew over time and you need to
expand it luckily that's as simple as
going here and saying increase my file
share and let that happen
so it's going to do that in the
background and your file system is
available for using in the meantime let
me show you a couple more things when I
try to create a file store instance I
talked about the performance on the top
right if I pick a premium instance
instead of standard you can see how it
shows the increase read and write I ops
as well as the throughput so again going
back to the design principles keep it
really simple when you're coming in and
creating an instance share everything
that we have to share about where it's
going to be created how large it will be
how much it is course cost you and what
are you going to get out of it in terms
of performance again it's not going to
change because of the usage of throw so
if you go back to this
if you look at the last one which is the
standard three you can see that it is
one-and-a-half terabytes now which
corresponds to the size increase that we
just played with again transparently
your workload can keep running and
you're not going to see a blip there's a
simple demo it hopefully shows you that
the product that we've been talking to
you so far actually works if you have
more in store for you and I give back to
tad now we switch back to the
presentation pretty cool fast demo there
right give you a good overview of the
whole the whole thing cashew demoed you
know from the from the GUI we also have
command line and API level access for
you as well all right so kind of you
know talking about use cases again I
just want to walk through a couple of
customer quotes that we've had for
customers that have been using this me
alpha and at the early beta process so
flywheel is a company that does a
WordPress hosting really really
important customer let's see this is a
really awesome quote we tested WordPress
in GCP on a veer Google Cloud file store
and an AWS on EFS and basically file
store was the best so super excited
about that web hosting of course is a
lot and especially in the WordPress land
is a lot of small file workloads and so
this is a really important
Charlie rice at everday I uses cloud
file store to distribute training data
to to build AI models for doing facial
recognition on a big proprietary data
set cloud file store was easy to
provision in mount and reliable for the
kind of workload we have having a POSIX
file system that we can mount and use
directly helps us speed read our files
really helps them you know every time
they are adding new training data they
got to regenerate it and if the file
server is slow then it's it's not
awesome cache you want to take this one
yeah this one is from a customer that
does processing on operating system
software etc the code from them is it
took one premium cloud file store in
Stan's prima is the one with the higher
performance to support a workload that
previously required 16 powerful servers
so in this case they have around 5,000
clients that are connecting to a single
file store instance and around 500 each
of them are active at any given point of
time in this case the biggest win for
them is they can get away from the
business of maintaining their powerful
servers and actually focus on first
testing and add value there so that was
pretty powerful if you think about this
this is the example of small file
metadata intensive workload that you can
try to crush the server with that cool
so file store is part of an ecosystem
not just a file store and not just
native products as part of an ecosystem
of partnerships and the partners are
good at various kinds of things and file
stores that good at various kinds of
things so when file store is not the
best choice it may be because you have a
workload that needs maybe scale out
performance in which case you might want
to go with somebody like a lass to file
there maybe you need a rich and deep
feature set or maybe you're working with
a vendor on Prem and you're beginning
your cloud journey and so maybe somebody
like NetApp is your you know your kind
of optimal partner there again you know
maybe maybe you need maybe have a lot of
distributed sites and they all are
sharing files for kind of desktop level
collaboration you know end-user
collaboration something like see Tara
and Penzer or awesome there and of
course there's many more partners for
kind of wide variety of use cases so
meeting meeting you where you are is
what we're trying to help enable here on
GCP and sometimes I don't mean file
store with a native product and
sometimes that's going to mean a partner
so we got you covered so that's enough
high-level is everyone's super excited
about demos yeah I like the everybody's
favorite part all right cool
so let me talk to you about media
rendering as kind of an interesting a
demo here so a typical process we see
with simulation artists is they fire a
bunch of simulations off at the same
time and then they're going to kind of
compare and contrast and then pick the
best one and that's the one they're
going to go send to a big big lar
scale render to do that efficiently they
need to harness a bunch of GPUs and they
need a you know a fast file system
shared in order to actually do this and
get the real-time feedback so this is a
I opted and this is a performance you
know kind of throughput heavy tasks
because we don't want the multiple
simulations to be bogged down you know
just because one one one of the Sims is
using up all of the i/o bandwidth all
right so let's switch to the the demo
screen alright cool so right so because
we offer you know high ups in the single
instance you know you saw in the earlier
slide up to 30,000 read I ops this is
actually possible to do with the single
instance on file store even though you
have a lot of simulations running kind
of spread out concurrently in order to
demo this I'm not going to run a
simulation I'm not a simulation artist I
have absolutely you know no graphic
design talent whatsoever so what I am
going to do is I'm going to show you a
synthetic benchmark running FIO which is
a very common tool that's used to do per
file system performance testing I'm
gonna do a 50/50 readwrite workload
that's going to test I ups and so this
is a file store premium instance mounted
on a single eight core VM on the client
side and running against 4k random i/o
is 50/50 read/write and then what I'm
going to show you behind here see I
don't need that anymore what I'm going
to show you is the metrics from the NFS
client here and you can see we've got on
the top left we've got read throughput
top right we got write throughput and in
the bottom we have aggregate I UPS split
into read and write
stacked on top of each other so just for
fun because what we're talking about is
I ops for this workload I'm gonna zoom
in on a ops here
and while the FIO script is pushing you
know all this traffic back and forth
from a single VM effectively what we're
doing is we're simulating a sim
and so it's Turtles all the way down
right alright yeah my attempt at humor
aside you know my my jokes to fill in
the time we'll the work that actually
ramps up is pretty funny alright so what
we're seeing here is the NFS client has
a this is performance measured at the
NFS client not at the NFS server because
that's what you really care about right
you care about what performance is the
client going to see and so the client is
a n1 standard eight with Prometheus
reporting agent installed reporting out
to a Prometheus server and then the
real-time stats being modeled with crow
fauna and so what you see here is I
opted combined I ops of north of 35,000
so close to 40,000 I ops for this
workload blue is read and pink ish is
that a pink is is right workloads and
let me get rid of those you don't need
those a little pop-ups there and so what
this is as this workload runs you see
it's doing a 50/50 read right and so
you'll see about equal over you know
over time to see about equal area under
each curve and then they're stacked so
you can see aggregate is 40,000 which is
pretty good you know if how many people
here have deployed file servers like in
there right forty thousand I ops a
pretty good number for a cloud files
file server yeah right okay for the for
those of you haven't deployed file
servers this is a great number and right
nobody's arguing with me so I assume
this is this is good and it's something
to look forward to is there's kind of
two truisms about storage systems
they're never big enough and they always
need to be faster again no quibble Sarah
right and so I think you can imagine
that over over time file store will get
not only bigger but also faster see is
there anything else I want to talk about
here I think that's that's basically it
you see the performance level I'm gonna
hand it back over to Kashi now and he's
going to drill down into kind of some of
our technical specs
while we're sitting back to the awesome
yes we were switching the screen I was
thinking about my product manager
promising to you all that will get
bigger and faster and I don't know how I
feel about that right now but thanks for
doing that I didn't commit us to a
timeline thank you
it's a fully managed service that we've
been talking about like most managed
services you've seen in the Google
portfolio nevertheless there are stats
and features that you care about to make
sure you pick the right one in terms of
sheer size you can grow all the way up
to 64 terabyte that's where the joke on
we need bigger comes in if you have any
feature requests we will have a few
links towards the end of the slide there
will also be a Q&A session and these
standards support channels and Technical
Account Managers will work to give us
feedback on what we could do to meet you
where you are in terms of share resize I
demoed that earlier you started
something small you pay for it you think
you need a little bit more in
dynamically you can update the size your
workload can continue to run it's not
going to see a blip right we're shipping
right off the bat with NFS we three
support with locks in terms of clients
the example that I showed you about is
beyond even testing I showed you an
example where a customer is running
production workloads with up to 5,000
clients around 500 active at the same
time so think of that as this scale
pretty powerful you get Google grade
encryption at rest
private IP the project that you're going
to use to create the file share is the
only place the shared VPC is the only
place the visibility will exist so you
do not be worried about any other
accident leaks and things like that it's
a beta product right now we announced 10
days back so while it doesn't have any
SLA guarantee right now in GA time frame
you can look forward to three nines of
zonal s-waves but that's just a very big
number right realistically you should
not expect more than a couple of minutes
in in the worst case of downtime at any
given instance and there too assuming
you're doing hard mounts
you guys are probably experts at this
you would not your application is not
gonna see any blood we talked about the
three ways of accessing it when is the
API when is the command-line and read it
through your demo we're exporting a sum
of the metrics to stag driver right now
you can read it off here again based on
feedback and as the product evolves this
would only get richer over time you will
have the ability to both monitor and set
alerts which comes standard with many of
our products in Google file store is no
different so we'll have during Q&A if
you have kind of you know detailed
feature queries definitely speak up let
me talk a minute about pricing and
availability so at GA when we go kind of
general availability in the future we
plan to be in every GCP region and so
that will but in the meantime while
we're in beta these are the regions that
file store is available in and in the
regional pricing and so as you can see
you know the you know the standard tier
is roughly twenty cents a gig per month
and the premium tier is roughly thirty
cents a gig per month a little bit of
regional variability there but not not
too much so file store is billed hourly
right and so you don't have to pay for
the whole month you only pay if you use
it you're only billed down to the the
hour and so you're talking like ten
thousandth of a cent per hour or
something there we go so on the
integration front we are already
integrated with a bunch of Google
products and a bunch of partner products
which I'll talk about in a few minutes
or we'll talk about in a few minutes on
Google side we're integrated with
compute engine kubernetes engine
deployment manager VPC networking and
stack driver some of this we've already
talked about and so we're not gonna
drill in there too much I want to say a
note about compute engine is that if
you're running on a batch process two
workloads you'll often be using
preemptable VMs which are fully
supported and the cool thing with
preemptable vm's right is they might get
torn down and a new one restarted for
you but file store will actually work
in that VM as well and it'll go down and
back up and everything so so that's
great cash she's going to talk to you
about our gke our kubernetes engine
integrations so I hope everybody got the
drift on GK integration in this
conference right so files your product
is no different we have a couple of ways
of doing that for you there is static
provisioning and dining provisioning you
can see a sample code yeah Mel on the
right I would personally not take that
and compile but you get the idea the
idea is you can use it using the
standard NFS volume plugging you create
the persistent volume claim plug in the
file share one way to obtain that would
be the demo I showed you earlier like
that in and you're good to go so it
should work with google kubernetes
engine we also have the dynamic
provisioning in the next slide and a big
shout-out to the gk team who we've
worked with internally using this we
just released to github the CSI driver
the URL is down there using that you can
dynamically create and mount these file
shares so you do not have your workloads
do not have to know about the existence
of them a priori furthermore you can
create multiple such instances and
dynamically attach them again sample
code is on the right the driver example
is all there and we will have more
documentation coming up so so message is
fully integrated with GK very cool so
continue on the integration front one of
the common things you need to do with
storage systems is is the dreaded backup
anyone here have had to do backups for
your storage systems for your files and
file servers never fun not super sexy
thing to do but you got to do it and you
got a test restores and you're gonna
probably have to do actual restores from
time to time so on that front chances
are you're working with some commercial
partners already there's some commercial
vendors for that already we're
announcing already an integration with
actifi oh and there's a solutions brief
and and they're available in the cloud
mantra right there and so a really cool
thing about Activia sky is it enables
tearing of your backup data
to GCSE into Google Cloud storage where
you can use near line in cold line as
well to further reduce costs there and
it enables rewind and restoration of
entire file systems or even just single
files at different points in time if
there's other backup providers that that
you use feel free to speak up during the
Q&A and and we'll we'll start to open
the conversations with them so wrapping
it up and just before we go to Q&A which
I think we've got about 50 and 20
minutes for so actually perfect timing
I want to leave you with a kind of you
know one key message here
right which is file store is a new
native experience for standing up
managed file servers in Google cloud and
it works with kubernetes Engine and
compute engine cashier you want to talk
about the resources sure so the web UI
many of that you who have used Google
products know how to get there
so we have a file store your eye towards
the end that's a standard way you can
reach out the overview and documentation
that we've listed here it should walk
you through the examples of g-cloud how
to use the UI how to create a file share
how to do the update and a bunch of
quick starts and tutorials so please
take a look and share feedback if you
have any on them and finally a couple of
mailing lists towards the end where we
will share information about what you
can look forward to and in return the
last one is where you can tell us how
the experience has been for you what is
it that you found good what is it that
you want to work on and what is it that
you want to work on us work on faster so
all that is awesome helpful data again
Vivaan beta product so looking forward
to all the feedback and making your
lives better in that process
[Music]